في ثاني أكبر مدينة في
أفغانستان ، إذا كنا ثلاثة ملايين
شخص ، فيبدو أن لا أحد يهتم حقًا بـ
9 11. كنت أتحدث إلى كل من
الأشخاص البسطاء المدنيين الذين كانوا يعيشون في ظل
الديمقراطية قبل تولي طالبان زمام الأمور
ويعتقدون أن الغالبية العظمى منهم
9 11  كان أمريكيًا تم إعداده في
دعاية أجريت مقابلة معه أمس أيضًا مع
مسؤول إعلامي في طالبان وتهرب من سؤالي
حول خطأ أفغانستان ومشاعره
تجاه الأشخاص الذين فقدوا حياتهم في
هجوم إرهابي ، لكنه أخبرني أن
الليمون الصغير كان في الواقع أحد أكثر الأيام حزنًا
في  حياته لأن الأمريكيين
غزوا بلاده في وقت لاحق ، وشدد أيضًا على
أن أحد الأيام السعيدة في حياته
كان اليوم الذي
غادر فيه آخر جندي أمريكي بلاده ، ليس من
السهل العيش هنا مع طالبان
وهم في جميع أنحاء المدينة يقومون بدوريات.
مع في سيارات الدفع الرباعي مع البنادق
براميل طويلة ولكن هناك انتقالية
يحاول الناس التعود عليها
ومنهم من يعتقد أنه أه
شيء واحد لا يمكن إنكاره  طالبان
هي نسبة جريمة منخفضة في الواقع
يعتقد الكثيرون هنا أن أفضل مزيج
من الحكومة هو
الديمقراطية ولكن مع اعتناء طالبان
بالأمن في البلاد ، نعتقد
أنه لا يزال هناك بعض الأشخاص
هنا يحصلون على جواز سفر أمريكي أو
بطاقة خضراء وتقطعت بهم السبل  أفغانستان
خاصة في هذه المدينة
مزاري شريف وسألت المسؤول الإعلامي في طالبان
أمس إذا كان بإمكان هؤلاء الأشخاص مغادرة
أفغانستان إذا كان لديهم تأشيرة أو بطاقة خضراء
، وقال نعم لا مشكلة
تحتاج فقط إلى أن تكون من خلال الكتاب ، فهناك
أيضًا معلومات غير مؤكدة حتى الآن
هناك  هي دولة إسلامية داش موجودة
حتى في هذه المدينة من أزيري شريف
فلاديمير بانيش